out the places where I don't think I've
been
I don't remember where I came from this
is walk here
oh oh oh [ __ ] Rob oh [ __ ] he was just
there
Oh like oh my god is nothing oh okay
welcome back I ran out of disk space so
what are my intentions Daniel they're
something patient
used to be yours but now you only seek
misplace quick oh wait there's worse
where I came from
No oh crap Oh do it again
all right welcome back the game crashed
because I ran out of disk space I was
recording in 1080p which takes a lot
more space and EGIS is still with me
hello
aigis monsters old also aging dude
what's up with that voice I thought
there was a game that's book hey what
happened what were we doing I forgot we
will go in back you were gonna shut it
and we see the monster something yeah
why was he the monster is oblique you I
think we have all the parts so let's go
back I guess I hope this I don't want to
go back in there
Oh
such feels he thought of go back go back
so what now
already been in there aren't you scared
stuff all over okay we're back to
Agrippa maybe he says something
different
maybe I heard the lyrics like different
endings in this game depending on [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what something is happening okay
oh [ __ ] this is very dark yeah it is I
don't want to waste my lantern
okay there is coming included you play
like oh I find this recipe I get it
aleksander is working on opening
we already know that he wants to go if
you could put your hangers
or you take your advantage let me pass
the take that
I carefully find XIII Pizza has a
chronic liar this guy
and - Sophie boy resettles appalled
that we are keeping you from illness
we'll only be bleached blush on time
unless everything
take care Oh
do we want saving yeah that's the
question I think we can choose if we
want to save him or not and that will
give us like a different ending what do
you think I don't want to save you don't
want to say mediator he's [ __ ]
disgusting you go so we're gonna skip
that right but we have to you know put
the pieces together somehow
yeah maybe helps us to do something be
sated yes Rob an appropriate workspace
is needed before the tart can be applied
so we are going to use the tar for the
word should we save him or not please uh
I don't care if you I really cared don't
care I just want to finish this game
Oh oh [ __ ] you forgetting about the
thing down here the water monster is
down here and the more what most is well
you're going to see him tomorrow and
tomorrow's episode
no I already been in there where did I
go in there ah oh wait I know where
we're gonna go
sorry you can see we're gonna go back to
where the monster started chasing us
I was horrible why would we want it a
Greek place very ugly yeah I don't know
to get a different ending I guess yeah
but it also seemed to be very the
condition to be saved yeah that's true
but I think he likes wants to save his
soul or something well I on no idea to
bonus and how we supposed to get to the
gate do you remember the yellow
lightning and stuff yep it's here and
he's supposed to be walked it yeah oh
that's what you man
I have no idea actually that's a good
question
okay creepy corridor Oh stuff is going
on stuff is definitely going on oh oh
wait your broom
Thanks I don't like blue lightning never
good news where do the colors idea what
the [ __ ] what am I supposed to do that
seriously maybe have to save him
are you kidding me I don't want to save
him mama sees me know what what
is your sanity go did you see that where
am I
yeah you're on the ground he took me to
prison cell he didn't kill me this is
meant to happen
Oh seriously
Oh aleksander captured me against your
day we are so very much the same
you can't hear him but he's talking to
me he said that I can read explain so
much
what you set out
you would face the old shadow
what you can wait here and stop the
shadow I can stop the shadow right that
would be awesome
yeah help I'll examine
didn't like that least scary way yeah no
I was horrible I need to find a way to
escape this any clues yep
we had a rope and a hazard rate it's got
to be the hammer it's in solid methyl
shape no use
but if there's a missing part here
there's got to be something with that
string maybe
I could use it on something I saw it
yeah there it is on the gate there is
something I can use on the gate
why should Glenn yeah maybe no tar no
bucket of pay who know what look is
around in the room
I don't see anything
business has always made together true
now the game ends here
that was sucky but didn't he say
something about wait for getting rid of
Shevin he told us to get rhythm yeah it
said wait though that's true there's a
lock on the other side the sellers lock
find a way out okay
all right
so they gotta be a hose away I get that
feeling also I don't see anything
go ahead
it's a small hole maybe I can drag these
like
Oh No kinky oh here's something
the bricks are loose there we go yep
mm uh that [ __ ] all right what is this I
can put my hand on it but I can't do
anything just gonna be so funny also
shows up in what what it's gonna be fun
if the monster shows up oh hello that's
it okay Nicolay dinner huh uh I can put
my hand right yet hammer again I lost a
hammer Oh a string it's gotta be the
string No
so maybe throw something out there I
can't there's nothing to throw it's only
then oh oh oh oh something's going on oh
oh oh oh oh this place is getting scary
the Pooh appeared so we'll maybe I can
use this though there's got to be
something right yeah but it's that's
really strange
yeah it always keeps Ray's boom-boom oh
ha ha ha ha oh my god what what
the bedroom it just [ __ ] jumped in
Kate drives on the die from the coop
yeah
it hits me
it looks so disgusting
I hate it I [ __ ] hate it uh tar no
poison again oh yeah good idea
no didn't work oh [ __ ]
it does a lot of damage to me I'm gonna
die if I [ __ ] up too many times okay so
you need to do something to get through
this Oh quite a job
hahahaha it did work I ran to it and
press the push good
oh-oh-oh-oh all this part is gonna be so
scary
why cuz the monsters around gameplay is
friendly now he's not [ __ ] friendly
takes you into person I walk out you
sound really loud are you close to the
mic
what did you say so it's multiple Alex
yeah it seems like he can control him
you want to read that no do you want me
to read a yeah last prisoner note
there's little left to say I write
solely to prevent myself from revisiting
the memories of these last few days I am
if I am fortunate I will fall asleep and
time will pass without effort I have
begun to wean myself of my prison when I
first arrived I felt like I was being
very buried inside a tomb but now I feel
the closed walls comforting me as long
as I am there here there is no pain the
walls protect me from the outside even
left earlier as one of my wardens
dropped the key down the pipes it gave
me hope for a second thinking I could
escape if only I could somehow reach it
from there oh there's a key down the
pipe apprently
in my dreams Alexander I am the king in
my dreams I best you and escaped your
clutches and returned with all the
Knights of the realm carrying pistols
and sabers in my dream
oh I feel bad for him but it did leave
us a hint that there
oh [ __ ]
there's a
let's use the string down there might
catch the key or something no we can't
Oh
what
what's going on